civil engineer marco pick inspects one
of his construction sites in estonia's
capital talon
it's thursday but he's already thinking
about the weekend
then like every year he'll be reporting
for survival training as a member of a
volunteer military unit and facing 72
hours in the wintry estonian forests
for the next three days i won't need to
deal with the problems at the
construction sites
my sole focus will be
surviving in a war situation
the next day it's time to move out
pig's team have packed their field kits
this weekend they'll go up against other
teams in a kind of scouting game
their rifle magazines are only loaded
with blanks but this is far more than
just a game
pick and his comrades are all too aware
of the current tensions with russia
the organizer might possibly have made
the tax even harder
because of the current situation
managers and white collar workers alike
as volunteers they're keen to show their
resolve
military service is the highest tribute
citizens can pay to their country
time to pack up
soon i'll be heading toward the russian
border
estonia's border with russia is 300
kilometers long and its population is
around 1.3 million
many here regard the threat of a russian
invasion of ukraine with deep concern
parliamentarians in talon have even
spoken of an alarming situation
many times throughout its history
estonia has come under oppressive
russian or soviet rule
the country's politicians have learned
their lessons from it
there is a very strong
united position among politicians never
mind which party you talk to
never again alone never alone again
so that means that one is of course what
we do ourselves our defense our
capabilities are built
very solidly but for from the scratch
during last 30 years
but secondly of course this is why we
value so much very close partnership
both within eu and
nato
but in a worst case scenario these men
want to be able to defend their country
without any outside help too
marco pig's team have been moving
through the forests for 24 hours now
they've been taking on one challenge
after another and finding new positions
all the while they hear distant gunfire
they take a little nap in the snow with
only their sleeping bags for warmth
at night temperatures fall below
freezing
at the moment it's very cold
we managed to rest for half an hour
under the tree
but our clothes are wet
these temperatures
they don't dry out
a checkpoint has warm drinks ready for
the volunteer reservists
soon other teams show up
women and men from across estonia are
taking part in this test of endurance
if called upon these units could supply
around twenty thousand volunteers
yet they know that in a war russian
forces would be vastly superior
in combat volunteers like marco pique
would take orders from estonia's regular
armed forces
they all hope it'll never come to that
even as they hear at the checkpoint that
the ukraine crisis could escalate at any
moment
[Music]
we're here at estonia's eastern border
at just the right place
if something should happen within the
next few hours
the blanks can quickly be switched out
for live ammunition
we're definitely ready
then they head back into the woods and
hope the next time they're here it will
just be for another exercise like this
one
you